i want to talk about transmission of
waves through the interface between
glass and air for example so if you have
a laser and my friend george has made
this nice little laser hey george say
hello
he's made this nice little laser and i
shine it
on this face of the
prism
it bounces out and comes in this
direction the light is coming down here
hitting this face of the prism
going through and hitting this face of
the prism and bouncing off and coming
this way it doesn't want to go through
it's totally internally reflected
oh so it seems
if i were to put another prism close to
it i could make something which looks
like a
a rhomboid shape and then if there were
no gap between these two
you might imagine that the thing would
come out the other side well i can't get
those to stick together so at this stage
i'm going to get a little bit of water
and make a little seal in between the
two just so that the light which can't
get across this air gap
can get through to the other side so if
i squeeze those together and put a bit
of water down there
all of a sudden you see it goes all the
way through and comes out down here so
you get complete transmission
so i would like to show you that thing
on a larger scale so you can get a a
picture of what's going on when the wave
comes up to this interface and bounces
off
so now i'm going to do the same thing
with microwaves this is three centimeter
radiation so it's about so long and the
waves are quite large scale this is a
generator of these microwaves and this
is a detector which i've hooked up to go
to a meter
this is a prism this is a prism
but it's made of paraffin wax
little beads of paraffin wax yeah pick
it up it gets everywhere on your hands
this is acting
as something which is transparent to
this microwave radiation just like this
prism is transparent to the laser light
coming out of there and because the size
is so small that the microwaves think of
this as a continuous medium it doesn't
see it as individual grains it's just a
continuum but it's extremely strange and
george has manufactured this prism out
of bits of sticky back plastic and
cardboard and now you can see that this
microwave comes in hits this surface
bounces off
as though it's a ping-pong ball bouncing
off a wall goes to here and actually
gets straight through and there is a
reading on here showing you
and they'll be on the reading on the
other one showing you that a lot of the
wave is reflected and because a lot of
the wave is reflected this is total
internal reflection of the wave there's
nothing coming out there so i'll just
shove this in the place which i've lined
up so this wave
notionally would come through here
hit this face
and go through there but it's not now
i'm going to do something amazing i'm
going to bring the second prism together
bit by bit by bit by bit by bit and when
it gets to about there you start to get
a reading on here and on the other meter
so as i bring it in suddenly it goes up
can you see that brady
and i'm bringing it in inching it in
inching it in and you get a nice signal
coming through so what's happening here
is the wave is coming out hitting this
surface going through this paraffin wax
going through this little bit of
cardboard the air gap i had and being
detected on the other side and then it's
going straight through into the detector
when that was there
yeah almost everything was bouncing out
this way yeah and yet when you move that
in
you changed it started going through why
what's it what's the angle got to do
with all this well the angle
in this case
this angle is such that you cannot find
a propagating wave that goes through
here that satisfies the boundary
conditions but when i move this in
you now find that this wave
somehow leaks through this region
and
manages to get into that region without
great difficulty